hey leute die masken sind soeben gelaunt
stellt der wienerstadt von de falls sie
also bock auf sonnemanns gehabt entweder
zwei oder drei lage ist ob mit draht
ohne draht wären verschiedene designs am
start anschaut auf jeden fall gerne
vorbei im nu camino shop.de dort findet
ihr weitere infos und der komplette
gewinnen wird gespendet
ich bin so stolz auf dieses projekt also
schaut dort gern mal vorbei allerdings
haben wir uns hier heute nichts sagen
autohändler
ich habe jetzt schon absolut keinen bock
mehr meine erste reaktion auf dieser
serie war mir an dieser stelle hier
stehen geblieben wie vielen frauen nicht
geschlafen habe ich weniger als 1000
ja
bei mir sieht es genauso aus ohne die
einst sieht sie euch ein zauberhafter
diese möchtegern reality stars die
glauben es erwartet sie ein brecher
sommer sie eigentlich dass lana heimlich
infos über ihr verhalten sammeln ich
werde die gäste beobachten und ihr
verhalten analysieren um ihnen zu helfen
bessere beziehungen zu führen es halt
das ding ja die leute die da mitmachen
wissen noch immer nicht dass sie keinen
haben dürfen für die nächsten vier
wochen zum glück lässt diese truppe eh
nichts anbrennen
ich bin überrascht dass sie sich noch
nicht in der horizontalen befinden
[Musik]
es ist der wahnsinn wie viele heiße
männer hier sind ich bin noch gar nicht
da hat er wollte ein schavan und de weck
und luca ich will sie an sprengen wie
ein baby gebhard mich an ihm fest
krallen und sie in mein nest fehlen
das sind völlig normale vorstellungen
übrigens habe ich einige kommentare
gelesen wo leute meint luca shuttle das
doch bitte auf englisch an und nicht auf
deutsch englisches wort die yellow from
egg studie die allerdings kann ich mir
vorstellen dass es wirklich einige dann
nicht verstehen würden von daher schaue
zweite auf deutsch ich weiß ein bisschen
crazy aber die serie ist auch wenn die
von daher hat sich das ganz gut ich will
harry zerstört
[Musik]
war harry der der quasi so ein kleiner
frecher kakadu ist ja wohl alles klar
gemacht so was auch manchmal sogar zwei
ich hab sofort ein auge auf ihn geworfen
ok
[Musik]
sie hat mit mir
aber ihr wisst ihr bescheid der unsere
lampen nicht die hälfte im buch wer
kommt denn da
wie findet ihr francesca 1031 kommst du
mal das model
die frage wen willst du wir brauchen
nicht noch so ein figürchen 59 schätzbar
francesca glory
ich brauche einen kakadu für hätte am
liebsten upfronts und harry's körper
gleich mit jesus habe ich noch nicht
oben ohne gesehen aber ich bin sicher
den würde ich auch absetzen
zusammengefasst würde sie jeden ablecken
gleich wird die raucher blair wäre lässt
das herz der jungs höher schlagen
bisher haben sich nur die mädels zu den
jungs geäußert die jungs sind alle heiß
ist meine favoritin der hammer ich muss
schnell miteinander sprechen denn ein
britischer akzent ist in amerika so viel
wert wie ein riesentor
das
bin ich der einzige der britischen
akzent komplett zum kotzen findet was
dein tipp ein mix aus heavy und
francesca oberkörper und
die serie ist und dann oberflächlich
[Musik]
halt alpha-männchen jahr gehe ich nicht
da ist mein rennen und was ist ein star
mit großer anziehungskraft technik los
angeles kam was willst du ich werde den
kinos und allem was heißt ich werde ihn
chöre aus und habe mir vor österreich
ist so ein fisch an oder ich nehme den
lack der da vorne schwimmt alle sind so
sexy wir haben für jeden geschmack was
dabei und karamell schokolade ist wie
der himmel auf erden und wir haben
[Musik]
caramel olade jesus die parteien sind
winzig ich habe das gleich mal getestet
und die betten machen kaum geräusche und
federn guten effekt für das was es mit
francesca vorhaben unser kakadu unser
kleiner frecher kakadu denn doch gar
nicht sein
seine rocky spruch spruch gebracht das
ist das wo wir denken das ding ich wette
es versprüht pheromone
[Musik]
tatsächlich macht das ding das komplette
gegenteil man ein kondom fahrrad mit
geschmack sind schön bunt
zusammengewürfelt wie kommt aus
australien
ich habe keine ahnung wo das essen
[Musik]
oh mein gott
und ich dachte wer dumm jetzt haben wir
schon chloe und haley
zwei lampen herz akzent ist toll auch
wenn ich ihn nicht verstehen
alles was nicht amerikanisch klingt ist
für mich eine soße
hey hey hey ich hab dann aber ich weiß
nicht was da drauf steht
ich heiße ja oder ja soll ich dich ein
krimi wie viele flaschen sonnencreme hat
er hier verstärkt was keine rückseite
david gefällt mir echt gut
ich habe das gefühl er weiß mich zu
nehmen er hat muskeln im guten arsch und
schöne blaue augen
warum man diese blauen augen und dazu
dieser sexy britische akzent
f wie ein großer ball aus purem spaß
[Musik]
ich setze mir das ding auch ich will
nicht noch mit was auch immer wieder in
dem steht angesteckt werden ich bin ein
clown interessiert sie sieht gut aus ich
mag diesen model typ dc us-meister
verlängern
ich glaube nicht an die ehe
ich meinte eher so vier wochen
selbst die hoffnung
bei den aussagen
ja auch meine reaktion 1 10 stunden noch
können dann immer ein bisschen vorspulen
das ist halt eine generelle frage die
ich mir stelle freunde weil ich hab
eigentlich walken mit euch auf zumindest
die ersten 12 3 folgen zu reagieren aber
die kommen überhaupt nicht voran weil
dann soviel verzapft wird auf dass ich
einfach der meinung hast du vermisst
ihr kennt euch sein sondern nur an was
dann lohnt sich nicht traut das liegt an
mir ist es komisch gerade nicht nicht
wow
ok
ich habe genug gesehen heute startet das
heutige video ist allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde ich hoffe
euch hat auch meine zweite reaktion
hierauf finger weg zur hände gefallen
heute mal wieder mit chloe mit hayley
mit mit dem francesca und mit allen wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann lasst unter
dem video gern einen daumen hoch da
schreibt mir bitte mal und in die
kommentare ob ich auch auf einen dritten
teil noch reagieren soll beziehungsweise
wir sind immer noch in folge eins aber
ob ich auch eine dritte reaktor zu
dieser serie noch hochladen sondern
jetzt befinden uns auch meine lieben
freunde wenn ihr die dritte reaktion von
mir auf dem weg in ein paar tagen nicht
verpassen wollt dann klickt hier oben
auf den spieler in eine welt der der
abonnent von meinem kanal wenn ich schon
ein klick auf die glocke bekommt ihr
eine kostenlose benachrichtigung wenn
ich mir hochlädt und hier ist ein video
verlinkt was eben auf meinem zeit kanal
online gegangen ist
[Musik]